Hello everybody!
Howdy, howdy, howdy, howdy!
Hi!
What happened?
What do you mean?
Am I okay?
Well...
Wait, when did I get...
Oh, when did I get actually?
Oh, never mind.
a spam call um um i was just on a trivia show hosted by nimi
nightmare on her channel uh me and phoebe fought valiantly
and my brain is broken my brain is broken my brain is broken
from trivia
so an eye blues.
Okay.
I forgot it existed.
Did you figure out what the problem with YouTube was?
Oh, it wouldn't let me start at the beginning of the stream.
When I was trying to connect to the stream earlier.
No clue why.
Just being silly.
So, yeah.
Tube is haunted.
Probably YouTube.
Haunted.
But yeah, so if you want to watch that, it was fun.
It was a lot of fun.
You can watch us be three sillies.
So that's on Nimi Nightmares channel.
But I was like, I still want to stream today.
We knew that Nimi's stream was going to be a little bit
short.
So I was like, okay, well, I still want to stream.
And I was going to play Power World tomorrow.
But I thought, what if I also play?
Play today.
I was like, what if...
What if I also...
Play today?
Kisses your brain, boo boo, all better.
Dummy!
I don't need to be smart if I have cute ladies all around
me.
Am I right?
You guys don't come here for my smarts anyway.
You guys...
You guys come for...
You guys don't care that I'm a big dumb hero.
You guys are in here for what you smarts are here for.
You're in here for some of the reason.
I don't know why, but you guys will watch me.
Don't get me, I'm over it.
Strike, thank you so much for that Super Todd.
I forgot to add this to the recommendations, but I highly
recommend Hocom.
I've been wanting to watch It's probably my favorite movie
above Project Hail Mary.
I love their portrayal of ghosts.
It's Alan Wake-Coded.
It's very, it's very like, it's like Eastern European
folklore kind of stuff, right?
My Oshi is big-brained even if she thinks green is a primary
color.
RGB, RGB.
The most important New York trivia is that show.
Chicago has better pizza.
Oh, I was just reading a super chat.
Everybody from New York, please don't eat me alive.
I'm already dead.
Hey, Minto, enjoying your upcoming vacation.
Also, quick watch along suggestion.
Ghostbusters.
I've seen Ghostbusters, but I guess it's been a while.
It would be fun to...
Would be fun to watch it again.
Hot dog.
Hello.
Hello, Minto.
And I was like, yep.
efforts in the trivia tournament today.
It was a hard-fought battle.
I also thought the primary colors were red, green, and blue.
No!
Green is not the primary because you mix it.
You mix the two colors to get it.
You have two mix to get the color.
But that's okay.
You fooled by gaming.
We here for amazing, cute, fantastic, Minto, no matter how
smart.
Exactly!
Depends what color system you're operating in.
Right!
Yeah, maybe I should have gotten the...
No, I'm just kidding.
Really like the keychain design that Ayami Mama posted.
The one where I'm like Koharu coded, right?
Oh my gosh, so many super chats.
Thank you guys!
Howdy, Minto!
Noticing the power world addiction and is in full swing.
Thanks for always being a pal and good luck on your
vacation.
Thank you!
We all know the real primary colors are pink and Green and
blue.
Wait, I should have written that instead.
To be fair, RBY are the primary colors.
RJB are the primary colors of light.
CMYK are the primary colors of print.
Then I...
Okay, if Phoebe could get the question for Spider-Man, where
were you guys?
You should have argued for me in the comments.
The primary colors are pink and green and blue.
Okay.
We tried to.
It's okay.
I still wouldn't have won.
Phoebe dominated that.
I don't know how she is so in tune with the horses and the
drag queens.
Her vibes were straight vibing.
My vibes completely off.
I've got bad vibes, guys.
That's why I gotta go to...
That's why I gotta go on my not vacation.
Oh, I was like, why am I so hot?
I forgot to turn on my fan again.
Darja!
Wow, it's been a long time!
Thank you!
Welcome back!
I'm weak to arguing against cute tape here, nurses.
You're so right.
I'll be thinking about... What was the one, though?
Olivia... Olivia Dreams?
That's such a good name.
That's such a good name, Olivia Dreams.
thinking about that one.
Type disadvantage.
It's so true.
You nailed that one.
Only, I feel like that one I was torn between VTuber or drag
queen because VTubers tend to have really funny punny names
as well.
I'm surprised you got that one but not a bag of chips.
It was bag of chips.
The drag queen?
I don't know.
I don't remember.
Where was it?
I think I said horse.
From drag race.
Drag race to UK.
I have never watched.
That's okay though.
It's okay.
It was still a lot of fun.
If you didn't watch it yet.
You can watch on Demi's channel.
Today, let's hop back.
into our pal where did i i was at base i fast traveled back
to base because in new york i hope you can visit the
building king kong climbed up what was that oh my gosh oh my
god they're on top of me get off of me um i was hoping she
would ask a question about that which building Did King Kong
jump up?
I was so ready.
I was ready.
But I did get to answer one question because of Metal Gear.
So that's really awesome.
Oh.
Yoink.
Someone made some Megasphere.
I can make some Meg.
Oh.
Or I can make my own.
Let's make a Gigosphere.
Thanks Metal Gear.
Hudson River.
Two years ago.
Yeah, Metal Gear is always helping me out.
Let's see.
Today, I want to explore this area and maybe go to here.
I don't know if I want to do the thing yet, but I want to go
over this area, right?
Invent, I come out of Lurking today to celebrate the 20th
anniversary of my 20th anniversary.
First birthday!
As a New Yorker, I only judged you a little bit on the quiz.
Name a happy birthday!
Happy birthday!
Oh, 20th anniversary.
Wow, time sure fly.
You don't...
It was like yesterday.
No, it was like yesterday.
Also, I saw other New Yorkers saying that they...
That they...
Didn't get all the questions either.
Oh, Brandon, I'm so sorry.
Eat something yummy today.
Eat something yummy.
I hope you're okay.
Let's wait for my pal spheres.
Very, oh good.
Here, I'll keep working too.
We'll make this go lots faster.
I didn't know a lot of them.
See?
And I knew a little bit.
I knew the Bronx and I knew Queens.
Okay.
But yeah, those are the two things that I have on the list
today is exploring this area and exploring into this area.
We're level 30 right now.
I want to be...
Oh, the other thing I want to do is revengeance on that...
tarantula lady.
Fun fact, Spider-Man is from Hell's Kitchen, Manhattan,
which is also the location in the MGS V-Types.
Metal Gear is always there for you.
But it's a location.
Hell?
Wait, which Spider-Man?
Wait, is that...
No, I thought he was from Queens.
Oh.
Oh, what?
It's Daredevil?
Oh, he's talking about miles.
Wait, wait.
Huh?
I'm getting mixed signals here.
I'm getting mixed signals.
Oh, we can upgrade this.
Enhance.
It's so close to enhancing the capture power.
Swimming ability.
Nice.
Wrong street level hero.
Oh, we're going to...
Oh, the nerds are really coming out.
in full force you guys oh there's a there's a waypoint here
let's go grab it let's go grab it oh i'm i just stepped i
took two steps outside the base my goodness
nerd fight oh what was that daredevil
that happened right next to me we've had i landed on my head
oh my gosh the guys are already there you are so
Unbelievable.
Free loot drop.
Something about it feels very...
What's the word?
Yeah, kill him.
Fortnite?
Not scripted.
No.
I think we got him all.
Back chill it.
Return.
Stamina.
Oh, sword.
I mean, not sword.
Take all.
Let's see.
Ooh.
I'll drink both of those.
We got some oil.
We got...
I got this make...
Oh, what's this?
Single shot rifle schematic.
Spider-Man is my Ocelot.
You can't fool me.
Oh my god.
They're eating the bodies!
Wait, wait, wait.
Let me take their stuff first.
This game is so metal.
Everything is...
As soon as they die, the vultures fly in.
They're crazy.
Uh-oh, wait.
I forgot my...
I forgot my deer.
We'll ride on.
We'll ride on Chillit for now.
Watch out.
Don't run into it.
Don't get angry at me.
Don't get mad at me, please.
And also...
Whoa.
Some of these guys are kind of crazy looking.
Catrice is so cute!
Wait a second.
Who are you?
There's something in there as well.
That I'm curious about.
This is...
I got this guy, Lupin.
Yeah, I remember him.
Chilla is so cute.
No.
Is that thing gonna get me?
Oh.
I kind of want you.
You're so cute!
I'm hungry.
Wait, is my bag empty?
Oh, no.
Oh, probably...
Everything came out when I died.
Oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh.
I dropped something, no?
Wait, I had something and I put it in here and it didn't...
Wait, where did it go?
It disappeared from my inventory.
Wait, why did it do that?
Oh, I already ate it!
Oh, oh, shoot.
That's funny.
Oh, Lubemon, you're such a problem.
Oh my god, just killing for fun.
No, he's eating the bodies.
I'm witnessing Mother Nature in front of us.
So scary.
Oh, here it is.
I just want to see what the thing is over here.
What the?
Who?
Loop moon.
What is this?
Oh, no, no.
Oh, 20.
Ah!
Let's get out of here.
Why are you on me?
Okay.
stuck in the wall not to be weird have you decided on a pal
husbando or waifu what do you mean the not to be weird part
oh oh oh oh oops oopsy anyway
um we were going uh to over here so we need to go
Oh my gosh.
How do I get out of here?
Just get out of here.
Just skedaddle.
Spider-Man and Aunt May actually do have a real address.
20 Ingram Street.
Forest, Hills, Queens.
The house regularly gets fan mail.
I believe that 100%.
Wait.
Catrice, please.
Catrice!
Stop running!
Oh, shoot.
Ouch!
Oh my god.
Screw it.
Yippee!
I still got her!
Hey!
Yeah.
Take him out.
Catrice has a really useful passive.
Does she now?
Uh, I don't even...
I don't get to see anything about her.
We'll get her again.
Oh, this one's 28!
Wait!
Oh!
Oh, shoot.
I'm trying to...
Oh.
Oh, shoot.
Oh, no, come on.
Come on, don't be like that, girl.
Don't be like that.
No, no.
She has a costume!
I got her.
Come on.
Stop homing in on me, please.
No!
Please!
Cheeky!
She's so cheeky!
Come on, come on, come on, come on, come on.
Yes!
I got her hair.
Oh, gosh, what's wrong with me?
We were heading towards this one, I think.
No.
But I do need to go west, for it.
I believe.
Don't attack me.
Maybe up here?
Why walking?
Because I, well I guess I can use Chill It, but I want to
get my deer back up base.
Maybe we go...
Oh, I'm like going so far around.
Holy cow.
Okay, hold on.
I didn't realize it was that far.
But also, please don't backseat if you can help it.
I am trying.
I don't want to go.
Well, there is this one north, but I'm trying to...
Actually, maybe I should get that one too.
I'm in the middle of both of them.
I went to both.
um maybe we get the north one and then i can teleport here
and go get this one maybe that would be the better option
maybe well divide in two i know right oh wait have i not
fought this guy yet i guess we can oh Level 21, lasso.
He's a cattle wrangler.
I'm going to take his pals.
Mine.
Oh, take your pal.
Take your pal.
Oh my gosh.
I think the birds are third partying.
I think they're third partying?
Hey, chill, chill, chill.
Chill, chill.
Chill it!
Nice.
There we go.
Good job.
Good job, Meowcat.
I think I took that bird.
I think I think.
Aw man, I wish I could have gotten the other one.
Secret.
You caught a boar.
Yes.
Yeah, okay, you got this.
You got this.
Nice.
Yoyink.
Now we go north.
Ride, cheleta, ride.
Oh, I have the new guy.
Somewhere around here so many secrets I know soon I'll be
able to get these guys too vantage point is it that one oh
it is it is it is who would have thunk every
time every time the server you didn't consume wait catruses
passive already fired you didn't consume a sphere on one of
the captures no way wait that's awesome okay oh you know
what uh oh okay now work yeah very good oh
we're gonna go over there today we're gonna go over there
Wow wish you safe travels for the next few weeks thank you
I'll try and see if I can do like some some what's the words
maybe some Twitter stream Twitter wait I'm out of fast
travel oh that's why some Twitter spaces the Twitter spaces
yeah but I don't plan on bringing my computer because it's
very very heavy well not very very heavy I have I have very
very heavy stuff to bring with me so if I did bring if I did
bring it it would be it would be a little difficult there we
go awesome yeah so so sorry so so so Sorry.
Everybody's chowing down.
Let's go.
I am going to...
Okay, so now we're going to go grab this one so then we can
explore into here.
So we're going to fast travel back to here.
Such travels have fun.
Thank you.
Yeah.
I have...
To give you an idea of other stuff that I have to bring...
I have over 300 postcards that I have to sign and bring with
me in my in my luggage so because that's for skyline
serenade hello just climb please please it is a lot of cards
so yeah Yeah, that will also be...
We can go up this way.
You think we'll...
Yeah, we can make this.
We can make this.
Surely.
Oh.
Uh.
Hmm.
Maybe not.
I said...
Um...
All the postcards are, we may be responsible for that.
You guys are just a little bit responsible if you are going
to Skyline Serenade and you got a vip card yeah you're
little you're contributing a little bit to my agony yes i'm
just kidding i made it to the back room so true
how do you okay there we go i was gonna say how do you quit
using oh no it's not open
i need to go up here let's grab this chest real quick
Ooh, ooh, ooh, ooh, delicious.
Alright, climb.
Climb.
Rest, rest, rest, rest, rest.
Yes.
Now, if I were a fast travel point, and then I see that up
there as well, where would I be?
yeah I do have a let's add more stamina yeah how many
streams this week today and tomorrow just two I'm sorry just
today and tomorrow and then I will be gone for a week and a
half ish week and a half ish yeah this should be able to
allow us to upgrade the base again, too.
Yoink.
Wait, where is it?
She's right behind me, isn't she?
Okay.
You wished for this, Minto?
Where are your freaky eyeballs?
I know.
And I wouldn't trade you guys for anything else in the
world.
Yahoo!
Let's go into this cave.
Probably.
We're probably fine, honestly.
Enjoy the Minto triple.
Oh, boss 29.
Do you guys think we can do it?
Hmm.
I think we can.
Let's do it.
Scary, scary, scary.
we do have we have uh oh not you i'm sorry chill it we have
meow cat we have meow cat on our side oh it's a giant loop
moon all right meow cat let's do our best and and if not we
got cat of a Take out the Giga Spears?
Whoa, this room looks awesome.
They're just chilling here.
Wait, why are they just chilling here?
Oh.
Oh, oops.
Wait, oh, wow!
Meowcat is too strong!
Oh, ow, ow, ow.
Okay, Meowcat, come back.
Oh, gosh.
Oh,
wait, no, not you, not you, sorry.
Go!
Okay, here we go, here we go.
Maybe?
Yes!
Yahoo!
Oh, I missed the other two.
Oh, they look so goofy.
They look so cute when they're knocked out.
It's so fun.
Yay!
Tactical Cat of a Burn.
Oh, wait.
Advanced Technical Manual?
Which I did pick up.
Where?
Oh, that's right.
I forget that I have to scroll now.
Technology points.
Nice.
We're gonna give some milk to Meowcat.
Is he another boss?
Oh.
Oh, yes he is.
Oh, no!
That's not what I meant to do!
Can I get through, please?
Oh my gosh.
Oh.
Is Meow?
No.
My cat is stuck.
in the ground.
I think.
Come on, Cativa!
You can do it!
Oh, yeah, you can do it.
Yeah!
Burn!
Oh, come on.
Uh, Cativa, I need you to not be in the ground.
There we go.
Yeah.
Get this guy.
And I'll send this to you.
Nice.
Burning on!
Come on.
Maybe?
B!
Oh, so some have two.
Very, very interesting.
Some dungeons have two.
I learned, I learned, I learned.
Is everybody okay?
I think my party's fine.
Yeah, awesome.
This is an insane early spawn.
really but we have him in our camp at our base we do have
him maybe they change stuff for the 1.0 right what did we
get this is oh the ancient tech yes stamina
yes awesome good elemental counter yeah right
Some have a mini boss room.
That's so cool.
We're going.
What a successful cave.
Helphadron.
I feel like I can take him on now too.
The world is like feeling so much more conquerable.
You know what I mean?
We can start taking on so much more.
Let's get this guy.
Wait, what do you mean?
you doing to him are you no now cat quit doing that now cat
too strong yeah which way was I going now well let's cross
over this river to the oh there's a there's a thing
cowabunga you expect that to make like a super crazy splash
a little disappointing maybe chill it is we need to fat and
chill it up to make the ultimate cannonball oh that's not
what I meant to dismount my bad put you away put you away
gotta tell the devs I need my my my pals to make like crazy
splash and you know that's really fun for me it's about over
here maybe
eggy you know fatten him up and he's gonna be afraid when
you unlock the butcher knife
I would never eat a pal I would never eat a pal a human
though is that there yeah
you likely already have no i haven't you have no proof oh oh
oh wait i wouldn't say my stuff stop what if the pal wanted
to be eaten i'm not judging your interests, but I'm judging
a little bit.
And we're on the board, folks.
38 minutes, 16 seconds.
That's soon!
Yahoo!
They said we're in bamboo territory, but I am not seeing
much bamboo.
What are you?
Ribboni.
Those arms are not just for show?
Absolutely not.
Sleek stroke?
We got carrots.
What's this?
Grilled gale claw.
I'll take that.
Let's see.
Who's hungry?
Maybe here?
Oh wait.
Does it not combine?
Is this also?
Yeah.
Why doesn't it combine?
Huh?
Oh, there it goes.
Where else we got?
Okay.
It didn't take the carrots.
No, it's okay.
I saw them and thought about it and then changed my mind.
Oh, there's something down there.
Oh, maybe I made a mistake.
Is there...
Is this, like, Minecraft, where if I fall in the water, I'll
be safe?
Is this thing going to eat me?
Oh, gosh.
We're fine.
It's friend.
Is it now?
Wow, they're beautiful.
You ever see, like...
I mean, I've seen a porpoise.
And I look at the porpoise and I understand exactly how
sirens were, uh...
Lady of the lake.
How sirens were like created.
You know what I mean?
You guys don't.
You guys don't see what I mean?
Is it that one right there?
Must be.
But we would get our butt whooped.
Red bar bad.
Green bar good.
Meen don't understand?
No.
I'm colorblind.
And you are being colorblindest to me.
I'm not actually colorblind.
I'm just trying to get it caught up.
Oh, I did it again.
Oops, I did it again.
Wait.
Oh, this is, like, not something to walk up.
This is, okay, there we go.
I don't know the difference between hills, apparently.
If you're actually colorblind, what are you supposed to do?
How are you supposed to know?
Oh, these are the evils!
We have another thing over here.
I believe it's over here.
What the heck are these things doing out here?
They're disgusting!
They remind me of those fish that can actually walk on land
that are so gross.
Some games have colorblind options.
Some games...
I misclicked.
Some games do, yeah.
It might be a mudfish.
Pal smash or pass when?
I don't need it.
All of them.
Oh, here we go.
Is it going to be a big one of these guys?
I have a feeling.
I have a feeling so.
Sealed realm of the sword master.
We could do this.
Wee could do...
Why are there so many of them?
Can I have any other pal, please?
Bushi.
If humans are pals, she said all of them.
I mean, do I chat.
I hope everyone's feeling good.
Unreal, citizen, thank you.
Hope you're feeling good.
Is Harum...
Is Harrow censored?
Oh.
Not yet.
Not you.
Meow cat.
Actually fire, so maybe chill?
Well, chill.
It's ice.
I don't have a water.
This is fine.
Meow cat is my all-rounder.
Whenever I play...
When I play Pokemon!
I uh...
Oh shoot.
No!
I just brought Meowcat back!
Oh, Meowcat!
I just brought him back.
Oh, oops.
Oopsie.
Get in there.
Oh well, it's fine.
Um...
I don't remember what I was saying though.
Oh, when I play Pokemon, I like use Gengar for everything.
Gengar is like my all-rounder.
He's too good.
How do I get out of here?
Hello, hello!
Nothing else?
No chests?
Disposing the evidence.
Gengar can do everything.
He can.
He's awesome.
We can always come back in an hour.
Okay.
One thing what we're gonna do is we'll come back here.
oh that's another that's a new looking biome for me oh it
says i haven't been there yet yeah yeah yes that's the one
okay cool all right let's go back i'm gonna upgrade the base
and that tug
Yes, Tombat.
Keep mining.
You.
And...
Oh, we need three.
Oh, you!
Nice.
First time catching you live.
Hello from Taiwan.
Hello.
Ever use any funny mods on...
On Palworld?
No.
Since I'm kind of new to the game, I've just been playing a
little...
Like, just the base game.
Nothing special, nothing special.
But thanks for checking me out!
Thanks for jumping, buddy.
There's a super cute little shark called the Epualet shark
that can walk on land.
He evolved to hunt in tide pools.
Wait, that sounds so cute.
Okay, we gotta get up there.
So let's get to it.
Oh, perfect.
The babies are asleep.
And now your friend.
Nope.
Nope, you're not allowed.
Don't touch me.
Don't look at me.
Nope.
Thank you.
Oh, big guy, big guy.
Baby car, thank you!
Oh, oh, they dropped so many carrots and things.
Oh, the...
Meow cat!
Can... I think Chillit would want to eat this.
Meow cat too.
Yeah.
I forgot to leave stuff at home.
I got a little ribbon though.
It's so cute.
Alright, we're going up there.
We got this.
Easiest climb of my afterlife.
Me and my 5,000 pounds of stone.
This guy is literally chilling.
Skonbot, thank you so much for the 20.
Thank you, thank you.
Ah boyish!
Welcome back, thank you.
Alright.
I scare myself with my eating sometimes.
What kind of trees are these?
Oh wow!
Let there be another one?
How?
Oh, I have unused points.
More.
Oh, I was really afraid we were gonna have to climb up this
entire thing.
Nice.
Nice, nice, nice, nice.
Oh!
That was close, that was close!
Green, what's that green over there?
I see several greens.
Eat your greens.
But be wary of the lettuce.
See, there's a green down there.
Is that one of those things for the base?
Nice, we unlocked this whole area Let's go There's two more
fast travel points That I can get She can show us the world
Shining, shimmering Splendid Oh, good day, launcher Holy
Ultra, wait, I got the Ultra Kill collab you guys Okay Wait,
what does this do?
It's armor.
Wait, wait, wait, wait.
Oh, meow mare.
Pre-wequisite unobtain.
Must defeat.
Okay, extra weapons.
This is huge, though.
I want the extra weapons.
Oh.
Let's see.
What else can I get?
Go with the carrot plantation.
Wait, that would be perfect since I've got some carrots.
Meow Mare is fun Is it?
Fires a bouncing cat projectile With each swing to attack
enemies Why does Mint's brain have a boo-boo?
Because I'm stupid, okay?
Gosh, can't a girl be stupid?
Fishing bond Signed a pal to fish here Okay.
And...
Power recovery grenade.
Neat.
Witch cauldron?
Place in base to improve medicine manufacturing speed.
Oh, here's the weapons assembly line.
Unlock that.
If... Okay, I'm gonna get the meow mirror.
And I'm gonna get the ultra kill collab.
Ultra kill collab.
I think that's pretty neat.
How many levels can I get to?
80.
Okay.
We're doing pretty well if I do say so myself.
Yoink.
I want to see.
There was something over here glowing.
I don't know if it was a dungeon or not.
Am I crazy?
Wait, I totally saw something glowing though.
I must be crazy.
I'm crazy.
That's not mean I'm crazy.
Leave me alone.
Oh, he's really coming after me.
Oh!
Oh, I just happened to run into it.
How faithful.
Minto has a head injury and everyone is aggressively head
padding.
Not the head injury.
That doesn't look open.
Wait, what's going on down here?
What?
What's with the candles?
Something's in there, though.
What is going on?
Is that just the water?
Huh.
I will do a little more attack.
Where our stamina is at 300.
It's crazy.
Wait.
Oh, there's another.
There's more candles.
What is the ritual?
Oh, this one is boarded up yeah there's so many around here
though there's always a secret behind the waterfall it's
true it's true it's true literally every video game will
teach you that
where are we oh here what's there let's go southwest a
little bit one day i'm gonna take on one of these guys
I'm running now.
Oh no!
Wait, the training manual!
Uh...
Here, we can just drop some meat.
Not the muskets schematic.
Not the poultry.
Please.
Give me the manual.
No.
Yes.
Let's use it on.
Uh...
The deer.
No.
I don't know yet.
Might as well feed someone with it.
I mean, we have so much food.
I guess we could.
Let's do it on deer.
And deer, you're also...
Here's impoultry.
There you go.
Now there was another one.
Oh, here.
So now we go up around here.
I think we gotta go like...
I'll just climb.
Hello, hello!
I mean, it's a good thing that I have massive arms.
Everybody made fun of me.
Oh, for my massive arms.
But wouldn't you wish in this scenario for arms?
they they say but we're climbing up today oh that's that one
right there i see it and so today i'll wish for some new
arms Is it you?
No.
I don't even know.
What are you doing here?
Oh.
Fanglope.
What is that one?
Wait, did I grab it?
I guess so.
Where is he?
There's some flying guys.
I'm looking for him.
Bangalope.
Bangalope?
Where are you?
Am I crazy?
I'm looking right at him.
Huh?
He's right here?
Oh!
It's a fast pal in the waterfall.
Ooh.
This is a great place for a base, by the way.
If only someone who created a second base had considered
this other base area that is so flat and nice, didn't you
present busted a bodybuilding musical?
I think I'm missing the waterfall though.
Hold on.
Oh, like here.
I want to see if I can take them on.
Down there?
No, that's not a waterfall.
I'm getting further.
It's like I'm...
It's like I'm playing Where's Waldo?
Under a waterfall.
There's a cave symbol.
I didn't see no cave symbol.
symbol backtrack by the fast travel this one look for a
waterfall i what do you think i'm doing
well not by the fast travel
down there what it's so far
wait is it actually this one right here oh hidden falls mind
craft oh
the one that I found earlier but it's so far how are you
supposed to know
oh you try oh oh my thing work oh i see oh oh oh oh oh oh oh
oh level 25 We can do it.
I'm gonna try with this.
Ouch.
Oh.
But you can't dodge with this guy.
I hate it.
I hate fighting on this guy.
I actually hate it.
Oh my god.
Ah!
Ouch!
Oh, dang.
Okay.
Oh my gosh.
Please.
Okay, okay.
You can sort of dodge with... Yeah, it's so tricky.
I guess it depends on the pal, maybe.
But...
They're so cute, though.
I need you!
Come on!
Oh.
Oh, whoo!
Hmm.
Maybe?
Yippee!
Bangalope!
Hard skim.
Can I- I'm guessing I can ride this guy or no?
Oh.
Mimmo.
I've seen that, but I don't remember.
Lailene!
Who are you?
You're so cute.
You totally can.
Yes.
Yeah.
Oh, shoot.
We gotta go drop off some stuff, man.
We can drop this because I'm just gonna discard it.
We have it.
What else do I have?
This one's rare, though.
shot rifle schematic like i don't need the musket schematic
take the training manual use it on maybe chill it get the 29
no not even wow okay if you stack five schematics and can
combine them really no that's news to me
here let's get out get back to the fast travel and go on
offload some things
oh my dear is so slow in the water so freaking slow oh thank
goodness
oh no that was a close one nice I don't know where I'm going
I'm just going up we're going up
let's not get this yet just kidding
oh nice you guys look how much we've taken down in this area
this guy is going to be tough this one a little tough that
one me not a little tough mammal rest soon that will feel so
good once we can take down the mammal rest don't zoom out no
i'm talking about in the area and you know it univote will
be able to get soon and tyrantress she's my tyrant temptress
yes she is we'll be able to get her blaze howl all right
let's go home drop some stuff yes yes yes yes yes and then
we will go westward westward bound
what is this thing open oh research oh my gosh what oh oh
what did i just do wait oh what it should i research
planting oh we need batteries research station well maybe
there's something else that we can get that's not planting
electricity yeah we can research this one okay
oh no wait there's a rain coming this place is just hours
away from being hit by some real nasty types.
Look at, he looks so casual.
No.
Wait, when does it come?
I don't see a countdown.
Uh-oh.
Stab him.
You're so right.
Oh my god!
Okay, he's down.
Oh, I was supposed to put my stuff away.
That's what I was doing.
Syndicate Raiders, okay.
This is fine.
I'll probably be coming from up there.
Yeah, there they go.
Oh my gosh.
Go, my pals!
Oh no!
Caught in the crossfire.
Oh, oops, that's not what I meant.
Uh, ouch, ouch, ouch.
Um, let's send out...
Meowcat.
Go!
Meowcat, go!
No, Meowcat, now is not the time.
Holy cow.
I'm caught in the crosshairs.
Holy...
Look at all their stuff!
I didn't catch a single one, but that's okay.
Hi, Meowcat!
Wow.
Yeah, we can loot their bodies.
It's awesome.
What else they got?
Ooh, yeah.
Oh, yeah.
Who's that?
Lots of ammo.
Alright.
Piles of dead bodies.
Yeah, and I'll do it again.
I don't stand a chance.
No duplicate items.
No duplicates.
Maybe in here.
None.
What's this?
Oh, gold?
Yeah.
Oh, no wonder he wanted to be a negotiator.
He's a broke.
He had 12 gold coins in his pocket.
We took him out.
What are you supposed to do with the...
Okay, let's do a couple things.
First, I'm going to eat these berries.
Let's...
Oh, I have a...
Wait, when did I get 15 large trading manuals?
One, two, three...
Four, five, six...
What level am I?
32, no?
No, I'm 31.
Holy cow!
Raid reward.
Nice.
Oh, I want to go sell my ruby too.
Catrus hair.
Soft and supple.
oh la la indeed
let's see I think all of the cloth or the wool I mean went
I'm just gonna I'm just gonna make another dang chest
everything is so already unorganized I should unlock this
big guy but it's fine don't worry about it Don't worry about
it.
Oh, that's not what I meant to do.
I'm just going to make another one.
Everything is unorganized.
Everything is all over the place.
One day, one day, we will organize.
Today is not that day.
Oh, I don't take those.
I don't know if I'll ever use them, but one day.
One day, it will all be... Who who put that in there not me
they're already using it they're already like oh my goodness
thank god we were so out of i only have eight i'm gonna
screw it that's fine i like my sword but maybe i should have
something long range well i do have my bow but i should have
something else long range no i don't know let's go sell this
what's this oh the kinship thing um I want to give this...
Oh, the Meowcat.
Meowcat love me even...
Is this our kin?
Yes.
Meowcat loves me even more now.
More items in my inventory below?
Oh, you're right!
It's just the oil, though.
Thank you, though.
Thank you.
I know.
It's so easy to miss it.
Down there.
Love means more damage.
No wonder Meowcat is so strong.
I love Chill It too though.
Hmm.
And I love the other guy.
Oh, look at you.
Don't run away from me.
Come here.
Come here, Mommy Meowcat.
Oh, my gosh.
She's so cute.
She's so sweet.
Meow.
Oh, you love you.
I love you.
you stop
no that's not your job I like the fire version of chili
because it's pink I don't even know there was a fire version
okay good we do have some of the high quality onsen it seems
nice in the grass oh this game is a treat all right
go over to here and make our way west.
There's loot in the expedition center.
Oh, I already laughed.
That's okay.
We'll grab it.
Nobody's out on any expedition, so we're good, I'd say.
On...
Oh.
Okay.
I like the regular version of Chill It because it's pink.
She said the thing.
Oh my god, she said the thing.
Oh, it's level 13 though.
Maybe we're okay.
Uh-oh, I'm starting to get...
I mean, it's not that I'm getting picky.
I was going to say, oh no, we're starting to get picky.
It's just that...
We do have to choose our battles.
A little bit.
It's these guys!
I love them!
Oh, yeah, sweet, sweet.
And sweepa, sweepa.
Hey, sweepa.
Okay.
You're mine?
They have no idea what just happened.
Yes, they do.
Oh my god!
Because they all have an idea.
Oh, they all have an idea.
Oh, shoot.
Every...
All of them are mine.
Every... every...
Everyone.
Everyone is mine.
Every Swee.
Every Swee belongs to me!
There's more!
It's like catching the whole fat...
King of the Fluff.
Wait, is that really the one that's around here?
Oh, wait, why are they so low level?
Mine.
Ouch!
Who's shooting at me?
I think though, for su- Well, Swedes definitely were fine.
We've caught everything.
But the sweep, I think, we...
Might be good in terms of...
Or no, not might be good.
I think we just need two more to get...
To get the XP.
Back in the day, there was multiple spawn locations when you
first started the game.
Hence, low spots on the bottom of the map.
I see!
That's pretty neat.
So we're kind of in a low area, but that's okay.
I'm going to enhance my work speed.
Yeah, when you die and you respawn area, you'll see various
starting areas.
Little cloth discard.
We don't need.
Oh, that guy was zooming back there.
saw well everybody everybody's aggressive everybody's
aggroed right now let's get out of here thirsty you guys
thirsty what is that oh rampaging dire wolf oh
holy cow he's he's he's fast wait I need you back and throw.
Oh wait!
Ow!
The catcher ate a zero!
Okay, never mind.
He's immune to my spheres.
Unless?
Yeah.
Defeated a predator pal.
What is that?
Giant pal soul!
Predator core!
Wait, this is all new to me!
What the heck?
They're like evil guys!
Oh no!
Wait, I wanted to switch my deer to the new guy, that new
one that we got in the waterfall.
Next time I come across a...
Oh, here it is.
We'll just keep going the way that we're going.
Oh, I see it.
We'll teleport home and we'll switch out.
Well, I have to make sure I have the saddle for it, but...
We'll see.
We'll see if I have one.
the sun wait wait oh that wasn't the waypoint it was the sun
wait i think i see it now for real
uncapturable have red aura is the the predator pals there we
go we got We got it.
She's navigating like a month.
Oh, there's the guy.
The guy that is on here, Noel.
We could go get him real quick too.
Let's see.
Sorry, I keep traveling back to the base.
I keep wanting to explore, but there's so many reasons to go
home as well.
Is this your first time seeing the sun?
I mean, do you see my complexion?
I'm basically see-through.
I'm so ghastly, ghostly.
Ooh, double jump well mounted.
Hard skin.
Fengalope.
I like fengalope.
The way it looks is so cool.
Um, let's see.
What do I have?
Not fengalope for sure.
Oh.
Technology.
When can I unlock a fengalope?
Oh, I already can.
Awesome.
Remember, new viewers, Mint is a cute ghost.
Cute!
I am extremely terrifying and scary.
I am haunting?
I am...
Frightening!
I am other synonyms of scary!
Terrifying!
Yes, yes, yes.
Cute is not what we describe.
Frightening, ghastly, or menacing.
Kawaii, not Kawaii, so...
True.
Omnis.
Oh yeah.
Yeah.
Window.
All right.
Cool.
We got the finger loop now.
Wow.
He's so pretty.
Holy double jump on this guy.
Oh my gosh.
I feel like I'm...
Oops.
My bad.
Don't get out.
Don't come at me.
I didn't see you down there, pipsqueak.
Dang.
No time wasted.
Very floaty.
So, so, so, so, so menacingly, terrifyingly, hauntingly, and
frighteningly cute.
You guys will rue this day.
the day you call me cute one day you'll see one day you'll
see oh someone else got a i almost had a predicon someone
else got the predator pal okay cool this one i know here
we'll use the training manual on you nice now you're back up
to speed with us
You will rue the day.
You know what I said yesterday?
You guys, I can't wait.
Disney is probably shaking in their boots right now.
There is a Paw Patrol movie coming out that has dinosaurs in
it.
There is the end of Oak Street.
You know what it is?
A dinosaur movie?
It is the era of dinosaurs.
We are so back.
And you know what they did?
They got rid of Dinosaur the Ride.
and they will regret it.
They are probably right now like, oh my gosh, why did we do
that?
Why, why did we do that?
We're so stupid, we're so stupid, we're so stupid.
They're probably calling themselves so stupid right now.
They will rue the day.
It will come to them that everybody loves dinosaurs now.
We are back in Dino, we are back in Dino era and they get
rid of Dinosaur the Ride because they're stupid.
They're so dumb.
They are probably, like, crying, sobbing, pissing, shitting,
throwing up all over the place with how stupid they feel.
And I hope they feel it forever.
Never forgive them.
Anyway.
Let's go over this way.
How dare they?
Exactly.
Whoa!
What is that?
Oh, let's...
You coming after me?
I didn't think so.
Eager to help with logging.
Why do all my pals want to help with logging?
Where was that guy?
Right here?
We lost him?
Wait, I lost him.
Mr. Man!
Oh, there you are.
Purple and menacing.
Crash.
Acid rain.
Just take him out.
Oh my god, it's raining acid for real!
This capture?
Yay!
We got crash in my party.
Oh wait, I probably need to switch to chill it though, we're
about to ride.
Oh.
We're fine.
Just mount.
What?
New man acquired.
I don't necessarily...
I want to go this way, but we'll go down and start riding
through the waves.
Here we go.
I want to go to the floating city.
How exciting!
How exciting.
And down there, too?
No, no, no.
Eye on the prize.
We gotta go.
We gotta go this way.
I can't yet.
I think I could.
If I really, really, really wanted to.
Is this part of the ancient ruins?
I want to know more of the lore.
It's so peaceful riding Chilot in the water.
I'm not going to lie.
like one of those like peaceful uh what is these what is
this like peaceful water fountains
intense heat oh whoa judge
woof we'll have chill oh chill it uh make us a little cooler
yeah chill it will make it cooler yeah exactly Nice!
Refined Metal Armor Schematic 2.
Let's see.
We're at level 33, everybody.
Let's go.
Good work, Chill It.
Chill It's so awesome.
Look how cute you are!
You know how cute you are!
I'm gonna pet you too.
Oh.
Okay.
Wait, is there anything like in here?
Wait, what's this in the tree?
What is that?
I gotta, okay, we're monkeying it up.
I'm a little monkey!
Oh, medium pal, soul.
Neat.
Anything in here?
I knew it.
I knew it, Jillit.
Anything in here?
No.
I picked the very right one.
Weren't you on holiday?
That's not... Not today.
And not tomorrow either.
Holiday eventually.
For now, you still have me to bother you.
Oh my gosh!
Oh, the red versions!
Oh, fine.
That's what you guys meant.
They're all chilling here on the beach.
What is that little guy over there?
He looks like Spyro.
Who are you?
Oh wait, that's Elise Punk.
I got this guy before.
Oh, dang.
Oh.
He had a key on him.
Yoink.
Had Spyro mentioned?
Absolutely.
I loved Spyro.
Loved me some Spyro.
Oh my gosh.
Wait.
We don't even have this area unlocked yet.
And I can see it with my own eyes.
The egg.
We'll get a little bit.
later oh it just sounds like one of those like relaxing
little like the water fountains that like don't really
they're not really fountains they just kind of like dribble
found 30 new areas oh they just like yeah they just dribble
a little bit love Spyro one and Yes, yes, yes!
What is this?
45, I think.
Not quite for me.
Not quite yet.
What is it though?
Is it this dude?
Would that be kind of sick?
Really cool dungeon.
When I can go in there, we will.
What the hell?
This guy's actually shooting at me!
Oh, he's level 35 too.
to get out of here?
Chill it.
We gotta get out of here.
We gotta get out of here, buddy.
That guy is stronger than us at the moment.
Not for long, though.
Not for log.
Oh my gosh.
These guys are dancing.
What are you?
Palumba.
Oh, there's so many new pals already.
Wow.
Generating electricity, pal.
Dang it, I don't have one on me.
catch him i mean we could catch these guys i'm afraid of
them attacking all of them at once though i think they'll
get get me well maybe not
maybe if we do like fox sparks just oh ouch ouch oh fox
sparks you're killing me you're killing me for real buddy oh
it hurts oh i'm on fire oh go get those got here I'll bring
you back until that
was close oh
my gosh okay I think we'll be able to get him now wasting my
hypersphere no I lost the 42% that's Crazy.
Fox spikes!
Oh my gosh.
Help!
No!
Oh man.
Well we got one at least.
Go back to our geospheres.
That was kind of crazy.
At least we got one.
What's this one?
Watering pal.
I have ice.
Turn around.
Fox Parks was thirsty for blood.
What a funny looking island, huh?
Oh, that's not what I meant to do.
But that's okay.
Honestly, kind of helped us.
Ouch!
No!
Come here!
Get on, get on, get on, get on, get on, get on, or get out
of here.
We'll come back.
Oh my gosh.
They're so aggressive.
I was gonna die otherwise.
I was gonna die, for real.
Ben Gloop is a water pal?
Oh, wait.
Really?
No?
Unless?
Oh, kind of?
It says neutral.
Just know some water moves.
Not quite a water pal.
Is this a actual town?
Fisherman's Point.
Are there people here?
Oh, nope.
Come back.
There are.
What are you doing?
Need more fire.
Hey, you there.
Could you bring me 10 pieces of hardwood?
To build a proper sacred fire, I need decent quality wood.
I hope you can help me.
The bar?
Sounds like it, yeah.
Hello, wandering merchant.
Yes, I would like to sell some things to you, actually, like
this sale.
Vigilante.
I wonder if we can find a vigilante bounty.
Wait, bounty office.
Exchange, exchange!
Oh, if I bring a plant!
Implant.
Oh, Power Verser?
Mysterious medicine that can change a pal's gender.
Whoa!
Interesting.
Life fruit.
Okay, so that's what these are for.
Who's making all this noise?
Who's making all that noise?
I think it's them.
I think it's them playing Smash.
Sensitive-nosed officer.
You're a pal tamer, huh?
Must be a decent one if you made it all the way out here.
Me, I was stationed in this village by the P-I-D-F.
To tell you the truth, there's been some trouble going on
lately.
I've actually got a request for you if you're interested.
Okay.
Right so, I was hoping you could look into a strange group
active in this area.
The Brothers of the Eternal Pire.
Is that the lady?
Lately, they've been challenging random people to fights.
Wild pals, too.
But they don't push anyone who turns them down.
They're not demanding money or goods, either.
Not knowing their reasons for doing so is putting the
villagers on edge.
You'll want to start by asking one of the locals about a
recent encounter.
Thanks in advance, Tamer.
Oh.
Also, I should grab this before I forget.
are you there's a pidf fellow over yonder ain't there they
say if you take them down down them bounties they'll give
you a reward i can tell you about the bounties around these
parts one and oh about the pineapple pizza enthusiast that
fella is a dangerous individual who destroys the very fabric
of pizza tradition yells pineapple pizza is the king of
pizza while barging into other folks meals and topping their
pizza with pineapple without asking I think I love this guy
if he's the king of pineapple pizza I'm the queen
traditional recipes crafted with passion by pizza artisans
over the years she ruined them with her devilish deeds that
sickly sweet juice kills the flavor of the cheese I don't
want to talk to you anymore shut the hell up I'm gonna kill
you gonna kill that guy.
I don't care if there's a bounty on my head.
Killed the
Let's see.
Whoa.
Where are we now?
We could go in, in, but it seems a little treacherous.
Dry sandy beach.
Oh no.
There's ways in, it seems.
Perhaps?
You tell him, Minto.
Yeah, I'm telling him.
I'm telling him good.
He frolics so majestically.
Fengalope might be my favorite mount.
I'm not gonna lie.
So awesome.
So cute and majestic and beautiful.
So far, at least.
so far listen to what the villager has to say oh i mean oh
there's a guy what if i stand amongst these storage bins
menacingly i'm just trying to go up oh go fengalup go
intense heat oh i'm gonna I think we have too cute of
clothes on perhaps for this area at the moment.
Why did it the heat resistance only happen now?
Men of Snake about to fault in those containers.
Even to this day when I see containers like that, I want to
fault in them.
Like...
MGSV has done irreparable damage to my brain in terms of in
terms of containers.
Why is Hunter?
Hey, I'm the one who monitors the bounds of this region's
ecosystem.
Sam?
It's so bad.
Can't wait for you to play again.
Me too!
Me too.
Right now I'm looking for someone who can help reduce their
numbers.
The pals?
However, I can't bring myself to kill innocent pals.
You on the other hand, you're a pal tamer, right?
The more pals you capture, the more I'll reward you.
Oh, I have unused points.
We'll do...
We'll do my health again.
You captured 100, not bad at all.
Thanks for helping out with the ecosystem management.
Here's a reward.
innovative technical manual thank you you're still short on
the 200 okay all right i gotta go talk to this person over
here right you star-loving villager hey you a pal tamer
what's that brother the eternal pyre oh sure i had a run in
with them with just the other day there i was haul This guy
is...
Are you thirsty, brother?
The ghost who faulted the world.
I know, it's so noisy.
You look like a dude who gets it?
Come on, let's pump it up!
I was too freaked out to do anything, but turned the guy
down, and he looked pretty bummed about it.
MGSV made me think of burgers in a different way.
So true.
They never used to get up in your face like that before.
You know, that reminds me, if you want to hear more about
the good old days, you ought to talk to the porter the
porter the porter in the volcanic area oh my god you guys
are so freaking
noisy hey hey
ride no ride where are you going
i want to go fight this guy over here too
let's see if we can fight him at all we'll come back
let's see wait but the other quest okay oh there's a thing
in there no um what no oh oh oh oh oh my god oh my god care
though you're you're attacking him and he's doing nothing
you're wasting your breath what are you doing you stupid oh
my god he's so dumb look at it look at them he's even he's
like he crouched down to even attack him some more
just are you stupid
take him I
think he's really dumb wait it's the golden it's the golden
one I tried to get before oh my god now he's going into the
water with him oh my god you
think he's gonna get distracted by the by the fish nope and
that guy he's just the least punk is going out into the sea
he says I'm done with this I'm done with this life.
Really, the NPC are just kind of...
Maybe we can take him.
I don't know.
Oh, there he goes, though.
Anyway.
Yoink.
Call of the sea.
If we go around here with Chill It, it might be easier,
actually, I think about it he's really just aggroed on that
one dude he cannot get enough he's in the water trying to
get him nice egg
thank you chill it what do you think we should do should we
get this guy I think I can take him down I think he's just a
little stupid oh
I think he's like incredibly stupid I think he's actually
so...
Smoke screen.
Has a flamethrower.
Doesn't know how to use it.
Typical.
Everybody's aggroed on that one guy.
What did you do?
You had your population.
Vibrates and place dies yeah like
where'd he go i want to catch him clearly he's oh here here
you are kelpsey no no no kelpsey come here i want you no no
no already oh oh my god
Where do you
go?
Okay.
He's gone, guys.
He's gone.
What are you guys doing?
Oh, you're generating this thing.
It's just so silly.
Okay, what can we do?
What can we do, guys?
What can we do?
civilization ruins.
There's all down around here.
Honestly, I'm curious about the the glacier over here.
Thank you for the joy you bring to millions around the
world.
Definitely not millions.
You'll be through the work week with your adorable laugh.
Keep me amazing.
Skeptic!
Thank you!
Thank you, thank you!
Good luck with the work and everything.
I love eternal summer.
Kyun des, kyun des, kyun des.
Kyun des, kyun des.
Ura messiah des, kyun des.
Ura messiah des.
Wait, I don't think I can make it.
I just realized my stamina.
Uh-oh.
chill it go back oh chill it chill it we're gonna make it
we're gonna make it
we're gonna make it chill it we're gonna make it we're gonna
make it we're gonna make it we're gonna make oh no oh
they're asleep they're asleep we're fine we're fine okay we
don't have enough stamina to go that way yet
poor bird does not know what hit him oh oh oh I just wanted
another one.
I just wanted another one!
No!
Come on!
Oh my gosh.
Thank you.
Maybe
it's fine.
Come on.
Yesoo!
Holy cow!
Okay, um, fast travel to heal, maybe?
Oh, oh, oh, oh, yeah.
Two down, yeah.
No logging, no logging.
Why are we logging?
Those are some shiny, shiny fish.
You know, now that I think about it, I have not tried.
to fish with my new rod.
You know?
I've not tried yet.
Let's try.
I don't remember
high quality bait.
I don't remember how to do this, actually.
Oh, nice.
Oh, shoot.
Oh, my God.
Oh, my God!
I caught a whole duck!
I'm free.
no way whoa oh cast cast aim and cast why want to cast why
can't I cast I'm trying to cast please let me cast cast oh
oh that's why because I was I was aiming on the the mouse
not the crosshair that's that's my bad
yeah nice and easy another duck Just a baby flock.
Wait, the first guy I got was kind of awesome then.
Shoot.
How do I do that?
Wow.
Wowie.
There's some more.
Pal-Sphere!
Okay.
Ooh.
That was a mighty swing for...
Just right here.
This is good practice, though.
What the?
Oh, my God.
Okay.
I ate some bread.
This is the last one I'll do.
Okay.
I can't tell if it's because I have a better...
Better...
Uh...
A rod now, or...
Oh, that turned into a shiny.
If it's a better rod now, or it's because, like, you know...
like they're not as strong of pals or something that it's
easier you know because before they were like super erratic
and everything kind of a little more like this
maybe both turticle
nice we're going into here and we're going to go Where are
we gonna go?
We're gonna go up in here.
Give him a gem, why?
Yep.
Hop.
Depending,
depends on the fish.
Harder pals to put up a stronger fight, right?
Yeah, I mean, I imagine that's how it's gonna.
Ooh, the heat.
Ooh, we be sweating, baby.
out chill it will help us out why is it so hot in here it's
getting hot in here all right chill it come on we're gonna
be traveling together for a second what do i want this guy
though wait i have one where did i get you don't quite
remember let's see um yeah we're like in an actual i think
Yeah, we're by the volcano now.
We'll go up into here.
Chill it.
Oh, yeah, just do that.
Watch the VODs of the Blade Runner game from a year ago.
I forgot.
That was when the V-Shoujo stuff happened.
Oh, it is really.
Genuinely incredible how much you intend to do in that time.
Thank you.
I don't even remember.
Honestly, I don't think about it like.
At all, really.
So.
It's funny how time goes.
What's this thing?
Chili, you coming?
Oh.
What is it?
Wait, is this a...
Is this the fake?
yeah oh my god he's fast wow he's wow he's howie wowie zoom
in oh my god no one will know no one would know no one will
know oh he's like a dog ah where'd he go wait oh there he is
God he's so fast hello oh my god oh my god oh my god okay I
think I need my bowl for this for this guy where'd he go
again oh my zoomies oh is that him no that can't be him oh
he was oh my gosh
he's not gone
oh he's taking like the tiniest bit of damage ever aggroed
on me so if I yeah okay good I didn't want I didn't want
chill it killing him we'll just do this for now it's not
super efficient but
why would it why would it say that I could catch him why
would it act like that I think we
Maybe I should have kept going.
I'm determined to get him now, though.
Oh, my God.
It's like watching a pinball.
Don't chill it.
Get out of the way.
Oh, my God.
Oh, no.
No, no, no.
There we go.
Oh, no.
Oh, my God.
I don't know if this is how he's supposed to run.
is this normal for this guy
he's not even taking damage
it is normal okay chill it i'm sorry oh chill it i'm sorry
yes
he's barely
he barely takes any damage i gotta get i gotta sword of
think oh if i can even reach him holy i do want him bad i
want him real bad he's my little guy he's my little guy you
know what let's just try again
come on come on
yeah new pal captured i was gonna say i don't think i i
think I think it said that I got him, but I don't remember
having dealt with that before.
Oh, what's this?
Nice.
Um, I think...
Who is that?
Uh, I'm trying to find the...
Oh, here it is.
There it is.
I was gonna say, I know I saw it.
You have seen but not captured.
Yeah.
Yippee!
Who are you?
Oh, Wixen.
You know Dasher and Dancer and Prancer and Wixen.
Comet and Cupid and what is this?
Horse ammo.
Why do you recall?
Oh.
Miss reindeer.
Whoa.
Wait.
Oh, shoot.
Oh, no.
Oh, I'm falling.
I'm falling.
Oh, chill it.
Chill it.
It's all over for us.
It's not even September.
Yeah?
I have my birthday first.
out of me.
I'm just singing a song.
The waves.
I don't think...
Is there anything else in here?
I mean, there must be something.
Oh, there's some... Okay.
Ways to jump up.
I wish I had double jump right now.
Oh yeah, there we go.
What's this?
Who do I need?
Oh, Oh, wait, we have, we have, we have!
Oh, wrong thing.
Get off.
Igniting?
Hurry up, because I'm literally dying right now.
Thank you, thank you.
Okay, we're good.
Yeah, I was on fire, like, a tiny, tiny bit.
But you know what?
It didn't matter.
Cast always...
Where do I read these?
away journals refined oh wait we new axes and stuff yes yes
old revolver refined metal spear barrel set electric polymer
ability glasses whoa summoning altar offer a slab depicting
a pal to offer a power to summon a powerful pal to your base
six shots let's see oh i saw it up here here we go and
i okay oh that's not what i meant to do oh gosh one
more time imagine it's a five shot revolver
We're good, we're good.
And we're going up to where now?
What's the next one?
Over there?
Yeah.
Okay.
How'd you do that?
How are you up here?
Buddy?
How'd you do?
How'd you get up here?
Oh, no!
Where the heck are we going?
No idea.
Oh, shoot.
That's not what I meant to do!
Ha!
Chill it.
away
all right one more time one more time it must be up there
but maybe they want you to climb part of the way oh well I
guess this is technically part of the way you're safe from
fall damage falling from wind jumps you are really okay good
to know chill it chill it I'll wait for you up here I hear a
another one yep oh there it is very nice and one over there
as well where am I going where am I going the revolver is
based on the old British Webley break top revolver such a
great gun both in game and in real life I see nice we're
just going we're going up for real Mount Obsidian.
Whoa!
Okay.
Five shots.
Maybe sometimes just enough to kill anything that...
moves.
Stop doing that!
Can you please?
Whoa!
I think I'm by the volcano.
I don't know why I gave it away.
Just a hunch.
He's so talented.
No clue how he does it.
There's not even any pals here.
Like, it's just hot.
At least I don't see any.
Bones.
Whoa.
obsidian watchtower oh there will be pals there will be yeah
chill
it i'll see you there oh right and by there i mean right
here
kind of sucks how fast your stamina drains using this thing
though the glide you have to get the upgraded one and then
you don't lose your stamina so much i'm guessing I can't
even climb I'm too tired I'm too I'm too sleep Oh hello
There are pals that help with that There's a pal for
everything isn't there
It's crazy Because I feel like I have so much stamina I'm
sleepy
I haven't even gotten to the area Though Where was it?
Flawless victory fixation.
I want this...
Definitely want this, um...
Fast travel, though.
Getting over here was pain in the butt.
Ooh, spicy.
Nice.
Clean.
Whoa.
We've seen this mountain so far away, but now we're finally
close here.
That's okay.
I was going to say, that's not the place I need to go to,
right?
Unless?
No, it's all the way over there.
I want to get to that.
Hmm.
Only one way to try.
Wait, I think I'm gonna be stuck.
I might have made a grave mistake.
Red.
Oh, he's coming after me.
He smells me?
I think, yeah, I do li- Why is he coming all the way over
here?
Yeah, I get- Oh.
He's doing a little jig in here?
What are those guys?
Okay, mold, Ron.
We can figure our way out of this, everybody.
We can figure our way out of this.
All right, watch this.
Oh my gosh, they're there here too.
Oh my god.
We got this?
Oh yeah.
Oh, I...
Who doubted?
should have nobody should have doubted chill it you're here
oh shoot yes yes yes yes yes nobody was should have doubted
ever yes you think those ponies are nice
hi rin oh oh I'm next to some real baddies.
Oh, gosh.
Chill it.
I think it's time for us to leave.
We'll come back here another time.
Never doubt it for a second.
I know you wouldn't.
Um.
Oh, nope, nope.
Come back.
Come here.
Oh, chill it.
You're on fire.
That didn't happen before.
Why are you on fire all of a sudden?
like okay you're fine you're fine
why were you suddenly on fire you silly scorching mine shaft
oh that sounds safe for us what's in here anything must be
something oh something
oh oh
Who's in here?
Whoa.
We can do this.
One.
Easy.
It used to be a boss fight.
Why did they replace it?
Fire support whistle?
What does that mean?
no harm so okay i'm just gonna get rid of some of these
seeds and stuff the hardwood remember that lady wanted some
i don't know where i got all this from being quite honest
don't know where it came from but no no carrot seeds uh give
me those fire whatever this is what is this when an
inventory unlocks recipe for fire support whistle yeah but
What does the fire...
Shall I eat some berries?
Very good.
And there's more stuff here.
All right, let's, um...
Fangloop can...
Level up?
Yeah.
Actually, everybody can level up, because I'm level 35.
Uh...
Fox sparks.
Okay.
Nice, nice, nice.
And let's get rid of some bone.
Everything that's, like, low...
What is this?
Leather.
Yeah.
Everything that we have, like, low amounts of.
Like, it's just kind of whatever.
Assault rifle schematic?
There's so many guines.
I can't remember which ones I've gotten.
I know.
Hmm.
Alright.
Come here.
You.
And enhance.
My health.
We'll go back to stamina soon though.
Alright.
We're gonna go back home and drop some things off.
Or no.
I wanna go to that village and sell stuff.
But.
I definitely.
I don't wanna go back to that one.
It kind of sucks.
We need another fast travel.
Is there anything close?
Foot of the volcano.
Yes, yes, yes, yes, yes.
One second.
Are you winning, Minto?
I am.
Renebus, thank you for the...
Super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
Ignis.
Lee's punk Ignis.
Okay.
Let's see.
It should be around.
Oh, no, no, no, no.
What is this?
Arsox.
Oh, I've gotten you before.
I got your big brother.
Oh, there it is.
There it is.
Nice.
You know, it was so easy to get here if you, like, went the
proper channels.
If you just, you know, like, don't climb the wall and
instead go up the designated path.
exists right here then it's very easy apparently well who
who would know that what that's crazy yes yeah
my way was really exciting and excitable and cool and
everything what do you think bushy this is the bushy from
before okay i'm getting i'm i'm getting caught up let's go
wait what's this oh who are you
looking for something if you've got a moment i could really
use your help i've been tracking this bat they love the word
bastard in this game this bastard who's been island hopping
setting fires to every forest they pass word is they're up
ahead but it's scorching hot My gear can't handle the heat.
Think you could teach them a lesson in my place?
I'll have a reward ready for you.
Okay, who is it?
Who is it?
Where are they?
She's cute.
Capture her.
She's a little outside my league, you guys.
Where's the guy?
Mission.
Hmm?
Submission?
The fugitive.
Track.
There we go.
Oh my gosh, it's all...
You think I can make it to...
Oh.
Oh, what?
I was just there!
Literally!
I was...
There was no guy there.
I'm sorry to tell you.
Ma'am, he's dead.
dead.
Ma'am, he's gone.
I'm so sorry for your loss or whatever, but it's over.
It's over.
You can fast travel there.
Oh, oops.
I guess I could have, huh?
We're already almost there.
It's fine.
We're almost there.
He's right there.
Chill it.
how to jump buddy he's like what do you what do you expect
of me i'm like all blubber oh my god
wait is it him
oh boy there's another one he's just the noodle guys
we have another genius out here all right let's get them I'm
scared though.
Yeah, there we go.
Oh, no.
Uh-oh.
Oh, shoot.
Chill it.
We might be outside our cup!
Tactical retreat, everybody.
We'll come back.
Whoa.
Oh, my gosh.
You're so pretty.
Uh-oh.
I know what you are.
Where'd he go?
Oh.
I know what you are.
Say it.
Vampire.
Actually, I don't remember his name.
Wow, they're so cool looking.
Wow.
I like these guys.
Okay, well that lady literally tried to kill us.
She may have sabotaged us a little bit.
Have you played any Metal Gear games on the MSX?
I have!
I streamed them even.
You can find them on my channel.
Joom.
Wee!
Oh my gosh, so awesome.
Let's see.
Where?
Oh wait, it's one of the evil pals, no?
Can I take this guy on?
36.
Possibly.
We are right next to a thing.
What are they?
Fire?
Oh, so chill it would be good if he wasn't recovering right
now.
I think...
Oh, that's not what I meant to do!
I think if we send them, okay.
could do it.
Oh, Lee.
Uh-oh.
Meow cat's getting a little beat up, guys.
Meow cat's getting a little...
Meow cat!
Oh, I'm screwed.
Uh, I'm leaving.
Mew!
Oh, that was ineffective.
I seem to be getting a little outside of, of, you know, Oh
my gosh.
No, no, please.
You're supposed to be friendly.
Oh my god.
I'm so dead.
Ouch.
Where is...
Oh my gosh, stop.
I'm trying to summon this guy.
Maybe a little underleveled for some of these things.
We're just being so... We're just being... We're just...
We're just... We're just... Oh...
Where is a thing?
I went completely too far away.
You can get this one over here.
Strategic retreat.
Look, I shoot my shot.
I see where I fail.
And I get the heck out of there.
Yeah, we're being ambitious.
That's the word.
We're being a little ambitious, perhaps.
Oh, I'm not climbing all the way.
Okay, hold on.
Okay.
yeah okay there it is there it is yeah yeah we got this
let's go home everybody we're going home if you fail that's
okay yeah sometimes we fail and that's okay so 36 is a
little outside my range it seems sometimes that guy was also
the flamethrower guy that was like such a recipe for
disaster though it was like so many high level things i
honestly shouldn't have attempted it it was so many high
level things all at once but we tried we tried what level am
i anyway i'm 35 um i will i will go to here and we're just
gonna sell some stuff and also i'm gonna give that lady some
things yeah we should upgrade my gear too you're so right
right yes yes yes 35 hag you you
Ruby oh and uh help what else could be sold I don't know oh
this one right yeah this lady wanted some things right need
more fire what did you want what did you want did you not
want wait mission oh my gosh request from white oh no 200
obtain a hardwood gather oh ten I have nine I don't even
know where I got these deserts volcanic regions and snowy
mountains oh I see have I captured enough yet You've
captured 200, not bad at all.
Stamina Revenue.
I'll drink that.
Thank you very much.
Where would a hardwood be?
Oh.
This?
Wood.
Hardwood.
More deserted areas, perhaps.
Anywhere with extreme temperature.
Oh.
That was weird.
It wouldn't let me move.
Okay, there we go.
Hardwood, hardwood, hardwood.
Yeah, it's too coastal.
Wait, we can fast travel.
I don't know what I'm doing.
I'm not thinking straight.
We can fast travel to literally anywhere.
And then...
Fast travel.
Let's go back guys!
Foot of the volcano!
My favorite!
Oh yeah!
You can give the hardwood to the lady.
It wouldn't let me though!
It wouldn't let me.
Maybe in here is okay?
Is this a hardwood tree?
Seems like it might be.
Perhaps.
Are you hardwood?
Hardwood!
Nice.
I think that's all we need to know.
Just the one?
Ten.
Yes.
Fast travel to the fisherman's point.
And then we'll give the lady her hard hardwood.
La la!
Alright lady, here's your one.
wood oh thank you this should keep the fire burning for a
bit longer stockpiling hardwood i wonder what kind of guy
the new head priest is you might learn something if you
visit that tower anyway care to join the brothers of the
eternal pyre she's one of i had a feeling i had a feeling
she was one of the freaks what do you have
armor belt a bull oh sweet cap wait I need a buy an easy buy
easy buy wait the daisy hat is so cute too daisy daisy is
this better than the stuff that
I guess we if I want to make it I can buy the stuff from
this guy I imagine he has some flame organ Here, I'm just
gonna buy like 10 of them or something.
20.
I'll buy 20.
I don't know how many we have back home.
Oh, I could have just bought some hardwood.
That's funny.
Let's go back home.
Okay, okay, okay.
Hire him for the base.
We used to have a merchant, and now he's gone.
I don't know where he went.
Someone took him out.
Oh!
Crash!
Yeah, crash!
Okay.
Um, let's see.
Oh, here we go, here we go.
Heat resistant metal art.
Oh yeah, he was selling the not metal version.
Oh, but look at that!
It requires way less than I thought it did.
Sweet hair!
Oh my gosh, I can make it now!
this so that I can still have my my head gear on oh that's
not what I meant to do my hand my fat fingered oh where's my
hat oh I don't think I acquired it there we go
wait what just happened capture wait what just happened oh a
visitor has arrived a visitor a visitor a visitor a visitor
wait are you the visitor negotiator wait another raid oh man
no if
it's a good if it's a if it's a peep not people raid i want
to have enough of these, though.
Another raid?
Dun, dun, dun, dun, dun.
Always shoot the messenger.
Absolutely.
We will kill him.
Don't worry.
Wherever you went.
I'm just making these real quick, just in case it's a bunch
of pals.
You do get really good rewards, it's so true.
Delargo!
Thanks for the Yep, dude.
Was I actually raided?
Wait, I can't tell.
Let's see.
You, come here.
Oh, ouch.
Oh.
Oops.
That's not what I meant to cancel it.
I'm so stupid.
All right, let's go.
I just wasted up.
Oh, it is the raiders.
Okay.
That's fine.
It's these guys.
It's okay though.
All right, come on, come on, come on everybody.
Where?
Where are they?
Hello?
Oh my gosh, there they are.
Everybody come help!
I'm not gonna do anything, though.
La la la la la la la.
I think I got everything.
Kind of hard to tell.
Where's the next raid?
Coming in from over yonder?
Oh,
they're in.
No, they're not.
Where the heck are they?
Why are they so slow this time?
Why are they so slow?
They're coming from the same way.
Oh, here they come.
Help!
Don't mind me, don't mind me.
Okay, don't mind me, don't mind me.
Oh, oh, they're coming in from this way again.pped what a
strange...
What a strange...
Oh, here they come.
What a strange location.
Assemble!
Oh!
Oh my goodness.
Ow!
Oh my gosh, you took me out of here.
I don't feel like doing anything though.
when i do that move i cannot um i can't uh move when i like
send out that thing you know what i mean get that guy now
take him down and take his stuff take it all take everything
he owns cool that should be everything
How do I do that?
I think people mentioned that last time and I don't
remember.
Or rather, I didn't learn.
What do we got here?
Wow.
What's this ancient PAL manuscript?
An ancient manuscript written on PAL hide.
It was maybe found during an expedition required for
advancing research.
Interesting.
In the party tab.
Oh, like...
Ah!
Oh!
The acid rain is the thing that I'm using now.
Quickly fires a burst of highly pressurized air.
Aqua gun, maybe?
Another great episode of the adventures of Luke Goblin and
the magical artillery artillery zoo versus coughing baby
infantry full of loot.
Let's see.
in here meow cat meow cat talk better yippee all right and
since we are level 35 i would like to also get my other
friends up actually
uh there is i have a large one though training oh extra
large
Extra large.
I wonder how much that will do.
Amphetamine, thank you so much for the pink.
Minto and a cold beer, the best follow-up to a 12, 12-hour
shift.
What's got here?
Good job.
12 hours.
I can't even imagine.
Oh, look at this.
Ragnarok.
Wixen, we got one.
Look at that.
We can set this guy in here.
Oh.
Oops.
Grabbed it.
Set the egg.
There we go.
It's very specific.
It requires a very...
It's a Clovey.
It's a...
Oh, another Clovey!
B guard.
Damp egg.
Who put all these in?
Oops, I'm stealing all of them.
My bad.
Amioni.
Bra-lola.
Will be.
I hope it was Mata, me too.
Oh.
Pinking.
Oh, you're doing your thing.
I definitely had put some in there though.
I don't remember.
Wixen.
Oh, they started level one there.
They're little babies.
They're actual babies.
I didn't realize that.
Wow.
Mata took one egg and now it's four.
Not only did she take one egg, she took my first.
egg.
She stole my first egg hatching experience after I was
waiting so, so long.
Therefore she must be eternally punished.
And I will never... You guys forget.
I am not just a ghost, but I am a vengeful ghost.
I hold a grudge and I will never forget.
go go go okay let's see what do i want to do now i still
i don't want to do the fugitive anymore i don't want to play
with you anymore get out of here stop tracking main mission
listen to what the porter in the volcanic area has to say
but he's like really in there no oh you can only track one
at a time I would have shown me both before.
Maybe we can get to him.
You sure are a kidder, Minto.
Put some stuff in the storage.
We could do that.
We can do a little bit of that.
Here, hold on.
How about you not tell me what to do?
How about I do it when I feel like it?
Which just happens to be right now.
And not because you told me to.
Wait.
Actually, I do want to get some better...
We got upgraded.
Stone pickaxe, metal pickaxe.
Do I have to get it from over here?
Let's see.
Was it this one?
I thought I...
I thought I had...
Unlocked.
Oh, here it is.
The refined...
Wait, refined ingot.
How do I make that?
I need a better furnace.
I think I unlocked that.
I think so.
You have the heat resistant armor.
Yes.
No, she denied the better furnace?
I have it in here.
Oh, Ultra Sphere!
Okay.
Improved furnace.
I have it.
I just needed to make it.
Here.
I'll put it right next door.
We're building.
Everybody.
Assemble.
Oh, no, I'm still working too.
I'm building, I'm building.
9, 8, 7, 6, 5, 4, 3, 2, 1 Happy New Year!
Coal.
Where do we get coal from?
Where do we get the coal from?
Yes, I make my balls.
Yes, slave over my balls.
desert has some okay i'm also working i'm working i'm
working all right
let's see oh did i make a large feedback that's my feedback
at the moment huge feed giant feedback although
Ancient civilization parts over here.
Oh, emerald.
We'll sell that.
Aquatic power fluids.
You can check on key items, too.
What do you mean, brother?
Sorry.
Don't quite understand.
I don't know.
Can I move...
How do I move the...
Oh, there we go.
Okay, right click.
We'll get rid of it from the exclusion.
some of these i'm not even holding anymore some of them i
don't really care so much i'm like you know what just get
rid of everything oh wait no my bait my bait i do want to
keep my bait i'll hold on to this too even right okay um
it's just this and this and some ammo that's going in anyway
yeah okay yes it's fine okay we're good i just like to make
sure you're not Clipped for reasons What was?
What did I say?
Wait, what did I say?
Oh no.
What did I say?
Awesome.
I didn't realize that we could get some hyperspheres from
this thing.
I wish these had better names.
Oh, the V1 armor!
I want this I want this It has heat resistance and cold
resistance Not very high Blood is fuel It features a
self-repair system that activates when dealing damage Wait,
that's kind of sick We need ingots That
Start working Actually, wait, why don't I just make it in
this one
Cancel and cancel where's the guy that will because that one
should be faster no oh where's the thing that oh here we go
set work mode no set assignment you wait improve furnish it
won't let me weird
I'll have to click on the circle first
I see I see I see
there we go come back come back my little friend there we go
yes there we go yes oh yeah oh yeah oh yeah was there anyone
no I think I think we got everybody.
Look at my...
Look at my army of Swedes.
I love them.
I love my army of Swedes.
Now I've got my sweet hat.
And then I have to make a mirror to be able to make my hat
not just cosmetic.
Sweet, sweet, sweet.
If you lock them to a station, they'll stay there and stop
randomly doing other tasks.
So if a multitask pal sometimes, It's better to do, let them
do whatever.
I would like to have him stuck on here.
I just don't know how to do that.
I would like to lock him in to our furnace, because I think
that's very important.
To have a furnace and stuff.
So many ghouls right now, I know, right?
Look at this, though.
The map is like...
Oh, I didn't even notice the other island over there.
Um...
was gonna say though is like the map is so huge and they do
a really good job at like cramming as much stuff look at all
these points so crammed together like they cram as much
stuff as possible into all of these uh areas and oh it's
kind of insane yeah
um we were making this
Did I make this the lockpicking tool?
Or did I use it before already?
Maybe that's why.
No, I don't remember using it unless.
Check your key items.
Can I even enhance?
Wait, how many?
Oh my gosh!
Whoa, I have so many!
Wow!
Oh, I didn't even see these, too.
Oh, my gosh.
Well, every time I get these, I feel like an absolute
hoarder.
You know what I mean?
Like, I don't want to give up anything.
I'm like, I would rather...
I would rather hoard everything.
Because I get, like, a decision paralysis.
I'm like, I don't know what to give.
Dude, like, I don't know what, like, Meowcat is gonna be
with me forever.
I can tell you that for now.
Like, worth it for Meowcat.
I feel like Meowcat, I would give everything.
I would give the world to Meowcat.
And for now, we can at least do all of these, because I have
so many.
You know?
I mean, work speed, we'll save on that.
Meowcat will never work a day.
And Meowcat will never lift a paw in their dang afterlife,
okay?
But everything else is great for Meowcat.
You can refund the souls anytime using money.
Oh, now really?
Oh, that's pretty nifty, isn't it?
I like fengalope a lot.
But I'm still...
They might not be my main mount.
I don't know.
You know, things are...
Things are awkward between us.
A choir?
There we go.
Chill it has been great, though.
You're so right.
chill it has been really awesome wait how do i how do i how
do i have too much item wait what am i being oh oh oopsie
wait i keep picking up ore somehow i don't know i don't know
how i keep picking up the ore okay
where did i pick all this up from maybe from there maybe it
was just on the ground puffled what are you sleeping there
for you dummy dumb you have a bed
yeah we're getting the v1 ultra kill armor we're gonna look
so awesome and sexy what if we look too sexy all right meow
cat maybe i will ask you to help just this once come on
let's work look
Stop.
Remind me of little pies, little baby, the resting bitch
face.
I love it.
Mother, why are you making me work kind of look?
Right?
And it's just making biscuits in the air.
It's so cute.
Thank you.
Where did this guy even come from?
Who brought this guy in?
okay guys watch this we're gonna look really awesome now
okay
oh i'm just
i thought it would be armor i did not know i would turn into
him
oh my god i'm just straight up the robot
i don't know how to feel about this
yeah i'm just a v1
with my sword with my sword what is this anti-gravity belt
increases the player's jump night star sand I
don't know how to feel about it to be honest I don't hate it
but I think it's very funny for for this you know I think
it's kind of silly
Hmm Anyway Um Let's Like you can't even see my hat You can't
even see my hat It makes me sad Oh, I'm naked now.
My bed.
That's awkward.
Antique dresser.
Yeah, I...
No, I've been told that a bajillion times.
I've been told that a bajillion times.
I don't know if I unlocked it.
Antique dresser.
Drosser, antique Drosser.
Oh, the Mega Glider!
Wait, I should have gotten that a million years ago.
Oh, it's a purple unlock.
Okay, thank you.
I was definitely not looking in there.
A Pass it?
Okay, I'll get it after I switch this out.
Yeah, the piano is very important for me, okay.
Okay, okay.
Awesome.
Yay!
Okay, now we have to go.
have a better glider even very cool very cool i i don't know
why i didn't do this so much so long ago okay um there
it is okay we'll just put it in here
furniture there we go nice wow they rushed in.
Yippee!
Okay.
Characters will be defenseless.
Oh, wow.
Oh, okay.
Wait, maybe we can change to a different hairstyle.
Oh.
Never mind.
Maybe the hat isn't my best option.
The fate of wearing.
wearing a hat yeah I kind of want to though let's see edit
appearance when did I get that maybe a twin tails for now
switch it up a little bit switch it up a little bit or long
hair is cute too kind
of matches a little bit I like the braid on this one.
We could go with this one instead.
But this one has my Ahoye.
It's so perfect.
I like this one too though.
You guys like my swirly eyes?
I gave myself swirly eyes.
Hmm.
The Mohawk?
Wait.
Where's the Mohawk?
Oh.
Bald.
oh this one yeah it's kind of sick that's pretty sick this
one's so pretty too this one's really pretty hmm twin tail
okay so on my head oh that's right we can do the bunny ears
i forgot my body will be no honestly i like having the armor
that i wear for in this kind of situation because I like
knowing if I'm having if I have the thing on you know what I
like the armor that I need to be wearing okay we're so cute
now I mean we've always been cute wait look at them jiggle
they are jiggling those guns you know it you know it oh
that's right I'm going to here we're gonna put away my hat.
We're gonna put away my armor.
We're gonna put away this schematic.
So many schematics.
I'm gonna put away this thing.
This thing.
The single ingot.
Okay.
Wait.
I have this gun.
I think I put away the bullets on accident.
I don't know where they were.
Oh no!
The shotgun bullets!
They're somewhere!
Oh!
I found them.
Oh my god.
Hey!
That guy I assigned to.
Did not come back.
What the heck, dude?
Pin, pin, pin, pin, pin!
I didn't take him off.
It takes coarse ammo.
Oh, it does.
You're telling me the gun that is called the shot... Oh, it
does say coarse ammo.
The gun that is called the shotgun does not take shotgun
shells.
Incredible work.
Oh, wait.
Yeah, that's good.
He was unassigned him at one point.
I did?
I don't remember doing that at all.
Back to the task at hand.
We're trying to get to this guy.
Our party is full.
So let's go to here.
And up, up, up, up and away.
As long as we have Chill It, we won't get too hot.
I don't think we need to change our armor right now because
we have Chill It.
Uh-huh.
Villager noises.
There are some scary guys up in here.
I'll be honest.
But I think we can handle them.
I have to get some rest before work.
Thanks for all the palling around.
Good luck with...
I think I'll call it soonish anyway.
Because I kind of want to play tomorrow.
Kind of want to play more tomorrow.
be able to play for a little while since i'll be away from
home unfortunately all right so we're just this is this is
new territory actually i'm pretty sure for me i think this
will be new territory yep yep
i'm pretty sure
What is it?
Oh, neat.
Medium, pal, so...
Oh.
Like I was freaking out just a little bit.
Oh, oasis.
Uh-huh.
Chill it!
Use waterfall!
Oh my god.
We're fine.
We're not fine.
What does that sound?
Don't mind me?
Where were they attacking?
Oh, you!
Wait!
Are you okay?
Oh.
Why can't I tell you?
talk to you hello is it because you died or why can't i talk
to you listen to what the porter oh oh i think he did die i
think he actually
he was in shock uh you want to know more about the brothers
of the internal pyre they used to be fairly chill for a
group that worships fire they kept to the mountain and spent
training.
Ian, thank you.
Could you tell me how to catch that cute pal right down
there?
That's chill it.
You can catch him any way easy as a pal, any way that a pal
is normally caught.
Yeah.
They kept to their mountain and spent their days training.
When they lost their leader, it seemed like they would
completely fizzle out.
That's about when their new head honcho showed up.
Some guy called Axel.
Got it.
Memorized.
Apparently the brothers found him passed out somewhere.
But he was a pretty passionate guy for someone who was found
down and out.
That really resonated with the group, I guess.
Ever since then, the brothers have been, well, a little too
hot to handle.
That's about all I can tell you about them, though.
If you're planning on digging deeper, try not to burn
yourself getting too close.
Report to the client.
Mega Ball.
I mean, hypersphere, whatever they're called.
Sphere, sphere, sphere, sphere.
Eggie.
Did I get this one over here?
I can't seem to remember.
Maybe not.
Don't attack me.
You don't see me.
You don't notice me.
You don't care about me.
I don't need.
you.
Hyper, something.
It's a ball.
Okay.
I'm ha- Oh, I'm hacking!
Wait, how do I do this again?
Oh, oh, reset.
Oh, there we go.
Yes.
Yahoo!
Metal bat schematic.
Metal.
What is that?
It's...
A flame organ in the wild!
Okay.
Alright, let's report back.
I thought he was frozen for a second.
Uh-oh.
Don't look at me.
I love no fall damage!
What's up here though?
Nice.
There was something here.
Yep.
A chest.
But not any kind of chest.
It's a chest of...
Watering!
Meteorite!
Where?
I hear it.
Oh!
Lucky!
Oh, no.
Oh, they're really strong now, huh?
Uh-oh.
Uh-huh.
They're like 36.
If I die, I'll end up like right over here.
Oh, oops, that's how I was it.
Just mount.
Alright, Meowcat.
No Meowcat.
No Logging.
Meowcat, no logging.
Meowcat.
Meowcat just wants to log, you guys.
Don't mess with my cat in his logs.
He just wants to scratch his paws.
Meowcat wants to log.
Meowcat.
He is eager to log.
That was actually insane.
I blinked and it was over.
Meowcat, like, one hit them.
Meowcat, the one hit wonder.
Meowcat, you don't have to log anymore.
Come on, buddy.
Come on.
This is so funny.
Over yonder.
But let me grab this first.
That's what they mean when they say one hit wonder.
It is!
If you have outdoor kitties, they will scratch, they will
like sharpen their claws on trees and stuff.
It's very cute.
Cats wish to scratch.
Hey, you're back.
Would you manage to figure out?
Oh, I get it now.
So this Axel guy came along and rekindled their dying
embers.
Yish, what a pain.
I mean, he doesn't sound like a bad guy.
It's just...
He's taking things way too far.
Sorry, but would you mind getting him to cool off?
Getting his butt kicked would probably damper on things at
least.
And don't worry, you'll be rewarded for the trouble.
Defeat Axel and the brothers of Eternal Pire Tower.
Where is that?
Oh, great.
Anyway.
We're not gonna do that.
According to Zoe, there are eight towers on the island, each
with a key sphere sealed inside.
Click them to solve their mystery.
Yeah.
Hey there, fish-loving villager.
I wish to speak with you.
Not a single bite here.
The old lady will have my head if I come back empty-handed
again.
If only I had a pal I could rely on.
And if it could fish for me, I'd live like a king.
And then I could ask it, Hey pal, you catch anything today?
That could be your life.
Alright, I want to at least...
Wait, where'd the tower go?
I don't think maybe I didn't track it I wish to see Where A
palumba saddle I can ride this guy too so fine I wish to see
Where The tower is at least And then maybe Okay sure yes It
said stop tracking but I didn't It's not showing me at all
now anymore Wait it's not showing me
Axel is honestly pretty easy since he's like a glass cannon.
Oh really?
We'll look at the water near that arcade.
I do see some fish at ease.
I'm looking at the water.
Looking at the water.
Oh what's this?
Depressor!
Uh, um, why is he in here?
I can't even move him.
Oh my god!
Why did you want me to see this?
Oh my god.
Huh, yeah.
I'm confused because I'm trying to see, like, the tower.
The...
Okay, wait.
Okay, hold on.
mission let's try let's try tracking this one again so
that's Axel and then tracking the main mission again track
there used to be something else over here
is Axel the next oh is he the next but it it doesn't show up
Axel is the next tower Uh-oh.
Huh?
The sphere ones don't have a marker since you need to defeat
the tower bosses.
Maybe what's confusing me is maybe this location was the
marker I was trying to get to before.
Right?
And then maybe when I did this, now it's triggering the next
thing, but I thought it was a tower over here, if that makes
sense.
So It's triggering the next tower, but I thought it was
triggering a tower over here.
Okay, got it.
Yeah, you did the quest already.
Okay, okay, okay.
Now it makes so much more sense.
That makes so much more sense.
I was thinking it was a tower.
It was this village where we did the thing thing, you know.
I'm going to go around over here.
We're just going to explore the...
the beach a little bit.
Next tower is the destination.
Yeah, I'm just looking around a little bit more.
Maybe we'll find a...
I want to like get the perimeter, you know?
A little coastal prance.
Yeah, a little nightly exploration.
Is this guy again?
I want one.
You're mine.
Wow!
That was close.
Shabby!
Why is he shabby?
It burns mysterious dark energy, matter is energy, and
expels the remaining...
Oh, just kidding.
We'll never know.
Mysterious.
Too mysterious.
Open.
Thank you.
here.
Ooh, we got lunch.
What
was that sound?
Holy cow.
Fengalup is awesome.
was, was it up here?
No, just kidding.
It's all the way over there.
Dry sandy beach.
Anyway.
Mine.
Come here.
Oh, just kidding.
Oh, oh, he's...
Oh, well, funny.
Oh, Fengalope!
I got you.
We're fine.
Yep.
Tyrant is faster, but Fengalope has double jump so he can
choose which mount you prefer.
I like the double jump.
It's so useful, no?
You hear that ghost be too I saw your Powell World video the
other day.
It was pretty cool.
I enjoyed it.
Well, thanks for coming back.
I do sure enjoy me some... Oh.
Powell World.
Yes, I do.
We're going to be able to get five of these guys easy.
Oh, wait.
Oh.
Yeah.
Strike that.
We strike that from...
We strike that from the witness stand.
We...
strike that he's eating perfect timing yeah i'll never oh oh
oh come back oh gosh he ran right into me no no
that guy i was like oh there's another one over there no
drive-by headbutt yeah right sheesh Come back, Fangalope.
Let's get this guy, too.
They're all ours.
Dang it, if only...
Oh my gosh.
No, Fangalope!
Is this ours?
Oh, no, wait.
I think I got him too early.
Maybe?
Nice.
All right, we just need one more.
We just need one more.
Obviously, we're not going to touch this guy.
I'm just looking at him.
What's like a good way to level up my pals then?
But I mean, I know there's the training manuals, but I feel
like there should be...
What is this?
Oh, God.
You scared me.
Wow.
But just by fighting?
No.
Let's get that guy before we...
fighting bosses okay okay oh dang it i was gonna like you
know i was gonna do the thing where we run into them and
then they get knocked over and they're like why'd you run
into me you scared me oh oh i
did call him back but i guess he um i guess he shot that
before i did so Come here.
Dang it, fengalope.
It's nearly daylight!
Uh-oh.
Stay away.
I learned my lesson.
I gotta thread the needle.
I gotta go through here.
Yeah.
Grab this eggie.
Eggie.
Pick up.
Don't grab the eggie.
We're gonna get out of here.
Intense heat.
Dang it.
Hmm.
Yeah, it's a super angry pal that we don't want to deal
with.
Let's do...
I don't think I've done my attack in a bit.
We're still exploring the...
Exploring the perimeter.
Oh!
Let's grab that.
Oh.
It's me.
I'm being the weirdo.
the weirdo guy that that jerks around on the map all right
she said stamina next to there she's not touching it okay i
did say that didn't i oopsie i forgot i forgot i'm just a
silly vtuber girl and i don't know i can't think for myself
I'm just a silly Vitor, and I've never had a thought in my
life.
Please understand.
I've never thought before.
You have to understand.
Wow!
And I want to go all the way over there.
Hey, Minto, what's the capital of New York?
Asking her for a friend.
Well, timeless.
You're asking the right person because it is York, New York.
York, York, York.
And don't let anyone tell you otherwise.
I hope that you're on who wants to be a millionaire and you
did phone a friend and you decided I'm the one who would
know.
Because you would know that I would know, you know.
Cool, because we did get...
Oh, awesome.
We did get Day 26 before.
The intense heat is hurting us a little bit.
Let's switch to chill it.
Oh!
Leave me alone!
Oops.
Anyway, what is this?
Am I hacking?
Oh, I'm hacking.
No.
Oh, it's this one.
Oops, my bad.
I'm hacking.
Wow, cute angel bottom right corner.
An angel?
Never.
Only ghost.
Refined metal helm.
Oh, nice.
Wait, that's actually really good.
And it's a rare.
Perfect.
Very good.
Oh, oh.
Over there, I see it.
Purplush?
Nice.
Those guys aren't going to hurt us, right?
The Helms for a Refined Lady.
You need coal for it?
Okay.
I'll get it.
I'll get the coal.
Yahoo!
What level are you?
What are you?
I'm just, okay.
I don't know.
They don't know either, I think.
They know nothing.
Who are you?
The Messenger of Love!
Hello.
Can I talk?
Can we talk?
Oh, I'm talking to Jillit.
Hey there.
I'm the Messenger of Love, an emotional expression.
I've come here to deliver the refreshing joy of your heart
desires.
Now let's try sit and chair.
Oh, I love sit and chair.
Nice, thank you.
Excel training manual!
Ma'am, you're too generous.
Uh-oh.
Wait, who am I?
Who's after me?
Oh, shoot.
Wait, I don't want to get the bad guy either.
That guy's way too scary for me.
Keep going.
Run, chill it, run.
Uh-oh.
Yeah,
you want to fight me so bad?
I dare you.
Jump off the cliff.
You coward.
You want to fight me?
You better jump.
You better work for it.
Yeah.
If all your friends told you to jump off the cliff, would
you do it?
Yeah, you would.
Because you want that fight.
Oh, wow, look at that.
We have the whole...
island mapped look at that guys exciting exciting there's a
whole lot of nothing in there just look wait a second though
is that a pathway do my eyes deceive or is that a pathway
leading to the very spot that we need to go to my eyes
deceive me or is that a pathway Can I help you?
Or can you help me, actually?
I do want to capture some of you guys.
For some reason, it does not like to register them at all.
Oh, we're back at Mount Obsidian.
Here we go.
Progress.
So much progress.
Yeah.
What are you guys?
Oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh.
Oh, guys, we need to ignore.
That's what...
Oh my god, who's the black marketeer?
This poor guy!
Oh no!
Oh no, he's gonna die!
Fight back!
Oh gosh.
He's cooked, he's cooked.
Nothing we can do about that.
Okay, what I'm gonna do?
Grab that fast travel area.
Right there.
I went up on the hill.
And then I'm going to call it.
Oh, wait, no, there's a dungeon.
Just kidding.
I'm not going to call it just yet.
We're going to go check out the dungeon.
Ew, get out of my face.
Um.
You know what?
I haven't caught one of these guys yet.
But I'm afraid that Chilot's about to obliterate him.
I'm on fire.
oh neat looking area whoa wait can i go in here 38 oh it's a
little tough oh let me get the fast travel first i feel like
we're gonna die in there
trust doable okay let me get the fast travel first the one
that i saw no oh i didn't even see one i saw that up there
okay what are you doing up here go away let's do it let's do
it let's do it meow cat sweep you're so right meow cat we'll
get it you got this Yeah, we got this.
It seems like a pretty large dungeon, though.
I do...
Oh, ow.
Oh, oh.
I do want to maybe try and capture him, though.
Yahoo!
Come on, Meowcat.
Don't do that.
You're scaring me.
This way?
Yeah.
He scared me.
Could I take on both of them?
I warned.
This friend will never notice.
What happened to your friend?
You don't know.
Oh, I'm stuck.
Oh, he didn't notice.
Ah!
Yeah!
I'll take you back for now.
Oh, shoot.
Meowcat, I need you.
Meowcat, you're in the lava.
Okay, good job.
This looks like a mini boss room.
No?
Nothing here.
Oh!
I hear a shiny.
No, shiny.
Oh, that's not what I meant to do!
We need to not kill him, though, Meowcat.
We need to not kill him, Meowcat!
Oh, I died.
I died.
I'm on fire.
How is it intense heat?
I have nothing on.
Where's all my stuff?
Okay, good.
It's all right here.
Jump.
Reach for it.
They're so mean.
They're like, come on.
Come on.
Don't you want your stuff?
Reach for it.
Please.
Get out of my stuff.
Oh, I was picking up the wrong thing.
There we go.
I was pressing E instead of F.
What the?
Now we have people.
Oh.
Oh, Meow Cat is down.
Meow Cat is down, you guys.
Chill it might be okay, though.
At least these guys, we can take them out.
Yeah.
Kill them.
We just killed them.
Oh.
I have low health, too.
I do.
I mean, I could leave.
Oh.
More guys.
Take him out, Chillit!
Ew.
Hey!
Nice.
I don't have any health stuff, unfortunately.
Chillit, we'll let you heal in there.
There we go.
I wonder what level is Chillit actually now.
Trust.
37 okay not bad not bad eat the berries oh my berries my
berries my berries actually we'll just do this
meow cat we'll feed you i promise we'll get you fixed up in
there i promise
we'll get you fixed up oh
there's no way where did you come from excuse me We're so
dead.
Go, go, go, go, go, go, go, go.
Go, go, go, go.
Chill it.
Distract him.
Yes.
Yeah, look.
Chill it's already half health.
He's got a type advantage.
I know, but look how much damage he took.
I'm scared.
We'll try it, though.
He's not rampaging.
You can take him.
all right let's try if i die again i die again i'm gonna
switch the bow though wait i couldn't even have time to
chill it you monster i didn't even have time to do anything
like legitimately okay oh get rid of the evidence okay all
right dang okay just kidding I can't believe I missed that
shiny though That kind of sucks A lot It sucks It sucks Wait
I'm gonna dismount you I'm gonna put you away real quick
Since I know this guy won't attack me He's chill, he's chill
Is that rock moving?
It is Whoa Can you come back?
Chill it had no chill.
Okay, we'll go the other way.
It's fine.
Easy come.
Easy go.
Alright, let's chill it here a little bit.
Hello.
Don't mind me.
Eating literal dirt and ash.
The world will turn to ash.
What do you think is over here?
Oh, my grapple hook.
You're so right.
Huh.
Oh, ouch.
Awkward.
Oh, my God.
I'm on fire, you guys.
The girls are fighting.
All right, chill it.
it's your time to shine baby oh this guy does not even he's
not even looking at us he's too frightened don't you mean
they'll eat ash yes i do mean that i do mean that actually
guard me
what's in here anyway a whole lot of nothing Chill it!
Whoop!
Oh shoot.
Chill it!
Help!
Oh wait.
Oh my gosh.
Yes.
Yes!
Nice.
Oh.
Maybe?
No!
My ball!
Oh I got it back though.
Let's go.
does that mean they'll eat ash yes it does chill it i need
your help buddy
whoa whoa whoa whoa whoa chill it actually i need you though
just in case let's put you back i think we got him i think
we got him
yeah okay chill it you need to really rest up in there buddy
Gary.
There's nothing in here except those guys!
Low on health, I know, right?
Holy cow.
I don't want this guy to notice me.
This is what happens when you go into a higher level
dungeon!
This is a guy.
I'll eat up.
Something yummy, yum.
Should be a chest in the far corner.
Should there, really?
Chest somewhere?
Maybe, hopefully.
Don't want to catch on fire.
Yeah, Chilla is really great in here, but he definitely
feels, he almost feels underleveled because he's like, you
know, he takes a lot.
Oh, wait, I got this chest, didn't I?
I think I got the one in the corner.
We didn't even need to go in, I guess.
Bottom right.
Yeah, I got it.
I got it.
But yeah.
This seems nervous.
Okay.
Oh.
I'm waiting for the grappling gun again.
And zero!
Chill, it's bad against fire.
Yeah, I can tell.
I mean, ice doesn't really...
It's not great, you know.
Oh, it's these guys again.
No!
I thought...
Because we defeated that big guy.
Wait, what is in there?
What's moving around in there?
Wait, did things respawn or am I crazy?
There's something moving in here, no?
Ah!
Oh my god, sorry, they scared me.
There was something moving.
There definitely was something moving!
Chill it!
I'm nervous, I'm nervous.
we could try fengalope i wish i could level well i could i
could level fengalope up more i could i could just use the
training manual why not let's do it yes oh it actually got
him perfect awesome let's go um fengalope i'm trusting you
look at him looking at me i feel so safe and protected what
if i also what if fengalope distracts them and i just leave
okay that's where i need to go buddies all right guys guys
come on they're like i we out all right we're out we out we
out we out what
if i hide right here
this is a sneaking mission now this is a sneaking mission
now
imagine if we had a gun yeah but also where did they go
Wait, oh.
They're coming back.
I hear their footsteps.
Oh, that's not crouch.
Don't be suspicious.
Get me out of here.
Okay.
I don't want to take on both of them at once.
I just did that.
Alright.
We still have to face the boss guys.
Isn't that like so cool?
Easy.
Sneaking success.
Wee!
Wait a second.
Is this the way I'm supposed to go?
I guess so.
Maybe.
I guess so?
Yeah, right.
No, don't do that.
What was behind that wall?
Oh, I can just jump it.
Okay, all right.
No way.
It's these guys.
I'm going to scream.
What?
No way.
It's these guys.
Oh, man.
They're such punks.
They're such, they're actually such punks.
That's kind of funny.
Nope, please.
Hey!
I'm just gonna keep throwing them at them.
What the?
Stop it!
Oh, I gotta be careful.
I gotta be careful.
For real.
I gotta be real careful.
Oh my gosh.
Nice, we got one!
Let's keep trying.
One down.
Oh, maybe?
Chill it!
We did it!
It wasn't a shiny though.
Dang it!
We were so close to getting the shiny guy.
Yahoo!
What is this one?
Burden.
Raise his carrying capacity.
Oh, God.
Thanks.
Eat up.
Read up.
Eat up and read up.
Vengalope's efforts forgotten.
No, I didn't.
I didn't at all.
I just forgot his name.
I had forgotten his name.
Oh, my gosh.
Scared the heck out of me.
I had forgotten his name for a brief moment.
Staminer.
Yeah.
All right.
Where's that guy running to?
What we're going to do is grab this eggie.
Who's that in the water?
Oh, it's a turticle.
Nice.
All right.
Then I'm going to grab this eggie and we're going to return
the eggies to home.
Huge scorching egg.
It's huge!
Lots of these guys around, huh?
Yes.
You could name him.
I could.
What should I name him?
Fangalope.
Fungal infection.
What's wrong with you?
Eggie?
Wait, I kind of like it because it's like Fengie?
Eggie.
Eggie!
Everybody be nice to Eggie.
Alright guys, alright guys.
We'll call it here.
I feel like there has to be more fast travel parts around
the...
Oh, there's one right there.
But I feel like there should be more.
Especially like over right here or something, no?
There's the one here.
in the ruined fortress city wow so much going on around here
we shall call it here i think we made some pretty oops some
pretty decent progress oh my gosh the map is there's no way
wait i can't get back wait i'm lost wait i'm lost wait oh
there we go wait the map is so huge the map is so
Wait, I'm lost again.
Wait, I'm lost.
Scouring island.
Let's go back home.
Wait.
You think we could take on that mammarist?
Pow world, not pow place.
Actually, though, actually.
Do it?
Mama rest.
Time, baby.
And then I'll call it quits.
I can't stop.
Mama rest.
Have I gotten enough of these guys?
Oh, yes, I did.
Okay, cool.
She has a problem.
I do.
Sorry.
Look, he's asleep.
It's the perfect time.
Fox sparks.
Oh,
wait.
Yeah.
Yeah, get on fire.
Come on.
Oh, Fox sparks.
Live.
Live!
You must live!
Catch him on fire!
Nice!
Alright.
Come here?
Never mind?
Yay!
Eggie, come here.
Oops.
Oh bad.
Can I fast travel?
I want to go home.
Can I go home?
Oh, you got him?
Nice.
Can I go home?
Here we go.
It's the Ammo Rest.
Oh, that was so exciting, wasn't it, guys?
Wasn't it, wasn't it, wasn't it?
Woohoo!
Woohoo, woohoo, woohoo, woohoo.
Nice.
I hope you guys enjoyed PAL World today.
I almost said PAL Rest.
I will PAL Rest.
And will PAL World more tomorrow?
I thought of...
I don't know.
I want to do PAL World, but I also want to do karaoke.
I'm deciding.
I did PAL World today.
I don't know yet.
PAL World or karaoke.
Part of me wants to just like...
Get out of my...
La, la, la, la, la, do both.
Dorigo, thank you so much for the ping.
I hope Alan around has made your head feel better.
It's much nicer to have eyeballs on your brain than booboos.
Yeah.
Good progress and nice writing to the end.
Good night.
Thank you.
Minto, I don't know how you do it, but you keep proving me
wrong every time.
You always come in clutch.
I won't doubt you again.
No.
Sometimes I do get in a little over my head.
don't i but thank you but sorry thank you good night minky
safe travels ahead thank you nesting resting what do i call
you when your account is weird sage thank you so much for
the five gifted fake me thank you for the pink thank you i
love pow world i don't know maybe we'll pow world and then
do a little karaoke although i when i pow world i literally
i'm like I'm gonna do this then I'm gonna do this then I'm
gonna do this then I'm gonna do this you know it's like so
hard to stop it's so hard to stop you think this guy's
better can be ridden while mounted increases logging
efficiency logging for or I don't think he's much better
than anyone else huh yeah Oh, the game does a great job at
encouraging you to keep going.
Right, right?
Resting glitch face is fine.
Okay.
Seeing every time you catch a pal.
Oh, it would be so much, no?
That would be so much.
We can increase our ability.
And we can enhance our pets.
Eggie, you have proven to...
be a valuable asset honestly i could get everybody up like
this you know
set the mamma rest to work on to flex on whoever logs in
next no it's fine oh wait that's right oh my gosh the winter
style chila is too cute
I want them to have outfits.
Wait, who else can have outfits?
Halloween!
Catrice has...
This game.
Catrice is perfect, you guys.
All she needs is something else.
She just needs a little modification.
Oh my god.
Party night depresso.
These are so funny.
Putting alagumos.
Whoa, golden.
Wait, how do I select the pal you want to apply the skin to?
Yo, chill it.
Yeah.
I wish there were more.
Is this literally every single pal that you can...
That I own that you can dress up?
Presso is so funny, though.
I have to.
They plan to add more.
Oh, that you own.
But yeah.
Remix.
I like Lucky Cativa.
Okay, guys.
Thank you so much for more, Pau World.
Thank you.
I had so much fun.
Next time, I definitely want to upgrade some of my gear um
so we need to get like lots of ingots lots of stuff um i'll
hold on to these for now so that we can make oh wait now to
make the it was the refined ingots was what um the ore and
the coal that's right where do i get coal from again no no
don't don't tell me don't tell me don't tell me don't I'll
get it next time, I'll get it next time.
But yeah, this is so fun.
I'm still looking at stuff.
Get off, get off, get off, stop, stop, stop.
Thank you, thank you, have so much fun.
I will see you guys later.
Bye-bye, bye-bye, bye-bye.
Bye-bye, bye-bye.
Bye-bye-bye-bye.
Bye-bye-bye.